well derek chauvin's guilty verdict to
spark reaction from civil rights
activists around the world among the
martin luther king
the third who joins us now uh thanks for
joining us
on sky news this morning first of all i
guess how significant a moment do you
believe this is
for the united states so i think that it
certainly
is an extraordinary uh significant
moment
because this has never happened
where an officer has been charged and
they have been officers convicted from
time to time
but this is extraordinarily significant
all charges
that he was accused of he was convicted
of
which means that maybe we can start
anew but there are a long
a long we have a long long way to go
this is
really just uh the beginning in a real
sense
there's so much talk today about the
change that needs to happen what do you
think would represent
concrete change out of all of the talk
today what do you think
america needs to see as a result of what
happened today
i would hope that the united states
senate would pass the george floyd
policing act
which is again just one step but it's
one significant step because
it disallows policemen to use the
chokehold and
and the other pieces of things in that
legislation
uh i think though we have to overall
take a look at policing in all
communities across our nation
and particularly communities the
policing as it relates to the black
community into the brown community
because uh there are serious problems
in how policing occurs in the black
community policing is
over there's over policing and
the reaction people are not treated with
dignity and respect people are not
treated like they want to be treated
they treat people very very poorly in
many cases
and that has to be addressed uh and that
has to happen
through uh city councils through mayors
through
uh uh through um you know through uh
the the state and the policing
authorities
uh so this is uh this really is a it's
it's not a sprint
it's a marathon
what do you think the message is to to
police departments to law enforcement to
the judiciary
uh around america as a result of of what
happened in court
what i hope is that this is was not an
action against
police this was an action against one
individual who
handled a situation um
that became fatal unnecessarily
uh and so it was barbaric it was
inhumane it was insensitive
it was it was final uh for george floyd
uh so tragically my hope though is the
message that is sent
is that you're going to be held
accountable for what you do
there are body cameras now that police
have to wear so everything is captured
from that perspective as well as their
individuals with smartphones
who are capturing and usually police are
not held accountable
so i think if if we are able to ensure
that yes you're going to be held
accountable
perhaps it may begin
a method of policemen treating people
differently
of course your father famously preached
non-violence we've seen
a peaceful celebration in minneapolis
tonight no sign of anything like we saw
uh
last year after the death of george
floyd by way of a reaction
what have you made of the reaction
across the country to
to the verdict today i think people
first of all were relieved
um you know just generally relieved i
i had something strange to happen um
in our home when the first uh verdict
uh the the judge read the first vetted
verdict is guilty
um our doors began one of the doors in
our home
just started rattling it it's it's weird
it was almost like the spirit of my
father
and mother were here saying okay we're
moving in the right direction this is
good
um it had not you know shake before then
but but getting back to the nation i
think
uh relief uh people felt really
positive people felt that maybe they can
begin to have
faith in the system again because people
have lost faith black people have lost
faith because the system historically
does not work
for the black and brown and communities
of color
we have to look as always at the
political climate in in washington do
you sense that there's a different tone
obviously as a different president now
from from when george floyd died
do you sense that the political climate
is right to see that change happen or is
it just more gridlock like everything
else
well i hope so but i do not know um
i am hopeful but i am not i don't feel
that oh wow this is one incident that is
going to cause congress to automatically
uh just begin to work with each other
and cause
enough votes to support the george floyd
act uh
there shouldn't even be any questions
about it passing
but unfortunately that is just not the
case
um i haven't heard any of the reactions
of our republican friends
uh we'll we'll have to see
it's it's the early hours where you are
i know it's the early hours here in
minneapolis
what do you think america will wake up
to tomorrow do you think there will be a
confidence
that things will change uh the the
attorney general here said this is
accountability in one case for
for justice to happen it needs to be
everyone in the united states do you
do you sense that will come and america
will confront that moment now
what i sense is that can come i don't
have a sense yet
until we see whether or not there's an
action
after this particular action and and
actually
not just an action many acts have
several actions
to address you know systematic
institutional racism
uh in policing to address the fact that
you need police from the community that
they police so they are
stakeholders they have a vested interest
in how
the policing takes place so that you
have more citizen review boards and no
you know written resistance to that so
that you have
um you know uh more psychological
evaluations that are more in depth
because we have to
understand who it is that we are being
who are being hired what kind of police
are being hired so there's a wholesale
review that has to be done um and i
think we're just going to have to wait
to see
i i'm i think this was a good first step
but we got a long long way to go
martin luther king iii there in atlanta
thanks very much for joining us